[Music]
good morning guys the first video I ever
uploaded to YouTube was my morning
routine and you turned it into a smash
hit now a lot has changed in my life
within the last year I have my new puppy
bear I finished my residency and I'm
practicing as a board-certified doctor
so I decided to give you my updated
morning routine with the help of my new
Lenovo smart display with the Google
assistant shout out so novo for
sponsoring this video let's get started
my mornings often start very early with
the alarm clock ringing and really
taking me out of a deep sleep don't hit
that snooze button it's gonna make you
feel groggy and make it even harder to
wake up in the morning the first thing
that I do once I get out of bed is open
the shades you want that natural light
hitting you as soon as you wake up not
only does it make it easier for you to
wake up but it also resets your
circadian rhythms so you can fall asleep
easier at night next I make my bed now
this hasn't changed from my previous
morning routine and for good reason both
psych and military experts alike
recommend making your bed it yields
tremendous productivity and willpower
benefits throughout the day once my bed
is all done I go on to brush my teeth
you should be doing this twice a day and
not only is it important for your dental
health but we've seen relationships
between heart disease and those who
don't take care of their teeth something
I know a lot of people skip out on is
flossing now I have braces in the back
of my teeth so it's not so easy to floss
but I use a Water Pik flosser it does
the same job shooting out a high-speed
stream of water getting that gunk out
from in between my teeth hey Google good
morning good morning dr. Mike it is 7:02
a.m. today it'll be cloudy with a
forecasted high of 69 and a low of 59
gonna be cold by the way you need to
film YouTube morning routine also don't
forget to go to your meeting the lenovo
smart display with google assistant has
my entire schedule in it it has my
reminders the weather updates traffic
updates in the morning when you're tired
and you need your routine to be on point
this thing has it all in one place
wait where's there hey
and good morning avoid you good morning
I know there I feel the same way
you ready eats the drink this is my
morning routine right here shower with
the dog and then shower in the bathroom
afterwards so bear ate and clearly he's
happy but I didn't eat generally I'll go
for some oatmeal but I'm not afraid of
doing intermittent fasting in fact
sometimes I wake up I don't have much of
an appetite
I do intermittent fast well let's get
the Lenovo smart assistant powered by
Google to help us out this morning hey
Google show me a recipe for oatmeal here
are some recipes hot smells good though
mm-hmm the reason you see me put so many
fruits into my oatmeal because I wanted
to taste good and instead of putting
sweeteners in I rather just put in more
fruits because the fruits have vitamins
minerals fiber so you don't absorb as
readily all of the sugars I think it's
the best way to do it mmm that's really
know what a bite bear ones like but bear
wants a bite of anything I take bear on
a walk every morning somewhere around 15
20 minutes he needs a nice long walk so
that when he's at home during the day
alone he doesn't destroy the entire
house that's a mistake I see people make
a lot if you saw my previous morning
routine video I was doing some
calisthenics in the morning now I got
this awesome stationary bike so I'm
cycling pretty much every morning gets
do like 20-30 minutes of solid interval
training so my heart rate gets better
burn some calories keep the weight off
all without losing muscle I always tell
my patients if you don't need to spend a
lot of time exercising in order to lose
weight one thing I have to do every
morning is do my hair as you saw earlier
in the video my hair is a mess when I
wake up the only way I can get it normal
is through blow-dry I use a little heat
protecting spray just because I'm
blow-drying my hair very often and then
I let the blow-dryer let the magic
happen and a simple round brush
[Music]
[Applause]
keeping it simple get a little hair
product clay or pomade whatever you like
using and then let it work its magic
[Music]
every morning before I set out to work I
like to sit right here on this couch for
like five minutes just focusing and I
know a lot of successful people like to
meditate but this isn't about sitting
cross-legged with your fingers touching
this is about being mindful thinking
about what's in your unconscious and all
that sounds deep but it's really about
thinking about what emotions are you
feeling what are you feeling them about
what's bothering you
and when you connect those feelings and
you're true about how you feel you can
be so much more productive throughout
your day I've definitely noticed the
benefit and it's something I recommend
to you at home now I need to get dressed
for work and depending on where I'm
working that day I have to put on a
different outfit for example if I'm
going on TV to do the news I have to put
on the full suit and tie I'm gonna be
working the hospital that day I put on
slacks dress shirt tie and then finally
I'm working the urgent care I throw one
of my scrubs because I don't want to get
my own clothes dirty I think it's really
important that you feel comfortable in
what you're wearing because it shows you
become more comfortable and when you
dress like a professional you get
treated like a professional it's time to
go to the hospital but first let me
check the traffic hey Google what's
traffic like going to work on your way
to work traffic is light as usual it is
35 minutes by car you can see the full
directions on your phone thanks google
so you have it guys my morning routine
is about to come to an end I'm ready to
get to the hospital don't want to be
late because I have patients and I'm
working until really late now the last
thing my morning routine is to drive
into work and ever since I was a kid I
loved sports cars and driving but now
I'm fortunate enough to have one now if
you want to share some of your morning
routine tips or something you do unusual
in the morning drop it down below in the
comments huge thing so lenovo for
sponsoring this video and letting me
keep the smart display the lenovo smart
display allows you to navigate and
command youtube with the power of your
voice so you can pull up my videos even
when you got your hands full and the
audio is fantastic
so you can listen to music when you
workout or meditate in the morning now
don't forget to send me comments and
share your morning habits down below you
know I love responding to you guys both
in the comments section and in my
monthly responding to comments video
stay happy and healthy you know when
you're feeling down sometimes you just
need a compliment hey Google give me a
compliment you should write a book about
how to be amazing it would be a
best-seller oh that's so sweet
[Music]